Peter Weber cutting ties when it comes
to his ex Hannah brown I mean I had real
feelings for him and I know that he had
real feelings for me but ultimately when
you care for somebody you want them to
find their happiness after last week's
cliffhanger and dramatic heart-to-heart
between the pair the 28 year old went
back on the invite he gave Hannah B last
week to join the House after the former
bachelorette admitted she still had
feelings for him but even though pilot
Pete decided he's not up for his ex to
compete for his love he admitted that he
is still very unsure about what its
heart once and Jutes all the confusion
he canceled the group date he had
planned with the girls offering up a
sincere apology I'm just not in the
right head space right now so just have
fun with you guys and just enjoying it
some of the girls didn't exactly take
the apology well it's calling out the
fact that Hannah has been a part of
their process since day one which isn't
fair and while Peter has decided to
focus on the women in the house we got a
sneak peek of what's in store for the
rest of the season
she means way too much to me and to me
of a few let her go could he be talking
about Hannah brown or will this be the
last we see of the beast and pilot Pete
so do we get an ending for you too
because if we're doing a math on how
much she was filming Dancing with the
Stars there's no way she was on your
whole season of The Bachelor there's
just not everyone thinks that but I mean
she's not filming the entire week okay
you know maybe the locations weren't so
far from LA so I don't know everyone
thinks it's not possible and I get that
but so are you and Hanna together right
now okay because he eats he sat down
with host Chris Harrison and he
explained exactly why they wanted to
have Hanna back on the show
is he over her is she over him I'm not
gonna get into that I'll let them deal
with that on the show but it's a thing
and there is some serious chemistry
between the two that's just undeniable
and that's why we wanted to have her
back on the show it's not just a hey I'm
here to hit you on the shoulder and say
good luck okay it's more than that
[Music]